luego de que estuvieron abiertos por
unas 10 horas los más de 17.500 centros
de votación en todo el país concluyeron
estas elecciones legislativas en
argentina en las que se recambia a la
mitad de la cámara de diputados y un
tercio de la cámara de senadores fue una
elección tranquila hubo algunas
denuncias de irregularidades por parte
de algunos partidos especialmente en
algunas provincias o localidades
puntuales pero fuera de eso fue una
elección tranquila los números ya
muestran que la participación fue algo
mayor que en las primarias de septiembre
en las primarias fue un 66% en este caso
en las generales fue algo más alta
estamos esperando los resultados
preliminares los primeros resultados que
van a indicar si el gobierno ha logrado
acortar esa diferencia con la oposición
que tuvo en las primarias en las que
sufrió una importante derrota en todo el
país especialmente en la provincia de
buenos aires donde el gobierno esperaba
hacerse fuerte o tal vez se refuerza el
éxito electoral de la oposición es algo
que veremos
las próximas horas cuando se empiecen a
conocer los resultados de estas
legislativas en argentina